today marks 50 years since the greatest
technological achievement in human
history the eagle has landed at 4:17 in
the afternoon Eastern time a spacecraft
carrying astronauts Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin touched down on the moon
nearly seven hours later and with an
estimated half a billion people watching
on TV
Armstrong descended from the lunar
module to take mankind's first steps on
the moon's surface I'm still getting
chills a momentous event was obviously
front-page news on papers across the
country and around the world and even
now NASA's Apollo 11 mission continues
to inspire America's next steps into
space this morning mark Strassmann is
back where it all started at the Kennedy
Space Center in Florida the site where
the Apollo 11 mission blasted off mark
has a feeling its excitements been
building all week honestly here if
they've had a series of commemorations
and reflections I have to remember on
top of everything else about Apollo 11
what fueled the first moon mission was
political will and Vice President Mike
Pence is here today to remind everyone
that this White House wants another moon
landing to happen Neil Armstrong
stepping out to the Sea of Tranquility
50 years ago today was a singular
American achievement it culminated the
work of 400,000 people over the course
of nearly a decade Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin spent about two and a half hours
outside the lunar module known as the
Eagle they collected about 47 pounds of
moon rocks planted an American flag and
blasted off to rejoin astronaut Michael
Collins who was circling the moon aboard
the command module but Armstrong and
Aldrin weren't the last people to walk
on the moon
NASA continued the Apollo program for
three and a half more years sending 10
more astronauts to the lunar surface on
Friday the eve of Apollo's golden
anniversary Aldrin and Collins reunited
in the Oval Office but the photo-op
turned into an impromptu debate over
where NASA
you go next with President Trump
seemingly siding against NASA's plan to
travel to the moon first before
traveling to Mars so how long a trip to
Mars how long would it take it's about a
seven-month journey there how do you
feel about it Mars direct you like it
directly it seems to me more as direct I
mean who knows better than these people
in May President Trump added 1.6 billion
dollars to NASA's 2020 budget to
fast-track a new lunar landing and we're
changing the culture we're saying we're
gonna go we're gonna go quickly we're
gonna go safely we're gonna do things
deliberately but we are going to go and
we're gonna we're gonna match the
rhetoric with the budget and we're gonna
do it in a timescale that is achievable
NASA Administrator Jim Bryden Stein
spoke with us in May to talk about the
revised moon program called Artemis we
landed there six times back in the 19th
from 1969 to 1972 but we're going back
this time when we go though we're gonna
stay so this is not going back to the
moon this is going forward to the moon
with the sustainable architecture we're
gonna prove technology we're gonna prove
capability the deadline of 2024 is a
no-go unless Congress approves the funds
there's a detailed plan how to get there
just know plan how to pay the
astronomical costs so there's no telling
when the next step on the moon will
happen and the next American moon
landing will reflect a half-century of
progress not only in technology but also
in social thinking because the next
group of astronauts to set foot there
will include at least one woman Elaine
all right mark thank you